the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
this is my first official video for my
own version of game of thrones season 9.
for those of you who don't know i am
writing my own version of what would
happen if hbo decided to make another
season of game of thrones
as you all know the final season of game
of thrones left a lot of fans feeling
unsatisfied
some fans thought the final season was
rushed some fans thought everyone was
acting out of character
some fans thought the characters had
dumb endings some fans were mad that a
lot of the mysteries were left
unanswered
it's no secret millions of fans were
upset with how game of thrones ended
i decided i would write my own season so
i can make things a little more
interesting than what we were given
i want to give answers to some of game
of thrones greatest mysteries
i want to bring back some of the
characters who were abandoned in earlier
seasons
i don't want them sitting on the
sidelines like they were in the final
season
i will also be adding certain aspects
from the books that were left out
after thinking about all of this for a
few days i realized this will not be
easy
i will be honest i'm not a very good
writer that should be obvious if you
have seen a lot of my videos
now i think i have created some really
good ideas for some of the characters so
far but that's about it
writing amazing dialogue and filling in
all the small details is where i
struggle
you also have to remember i am writing
each episode over the span of a few days
the writers for game of thrones had at
least six months and they also had
assistance
i'm not making these videos because i
think i'm some amazing author or
anything like that
i did not go to school to become a
writer i'm sure i will make a lot of
mistakes along the way
i just hope i can give the characters a
more interesting and hopefully
more satisfying ending we shall see now
that i got all of that out of the way
let's jump into the first episode some
of you may have already seen my recent
video where i showed you my version of
the opening scene
in that video i showed scenes from brain
stark's flashbacks
and one thing i did not mention in that
video is when bran stark had the
flashbacks
if you remember in brian stark's final
scene in game of thrones he
says he will go find drogon then we see
him leave the small council meeting
well right after that scene bran is left
alone in his bed chamber
and when he goes looking for drogon he
also has all of these flashbacks in that
same moment
i will start this video by showing those
again because you will need to remember
those if you're gonna understand how
this season will unfold
in the first flashback scene we are back
inside the three-eyed ravens cave
we will see brain stark the three-eyed
raven and leaf having a conversation
hodor and mira reed are off screen
sitting outside the cave
where we have seen them sit before this
is when we will see the three odd raven
and leaf
explain how bran's visions will work
what they say to him is lifted right out
of the books
although i did make some of my own minor
changes
we hear the three-eyed raven say a
weirwood will live forever
if left undisturbed for them seasons
come and go in the flutter of a bird's
wing
and past present and future are one
nor will your sight be limited to your
god's wood the singers carved eyes into
their heart trees to awaken them
and those are the first eyes a new
greenseer learns to use
in time you will be able to see well
beyond the trees themselves
now remember what was said here because
this has major implications for bran
stark's abilities
this lets us know bran won't always need
the werewolves for him to be able to see
things it also indicates he might be
able to see future events as well
then we cut to another flashback scene
now we see a massive red building
and standing outside of that building is
hundreds of followers overlore
who are all dressed in red robes all of
them are looking at the sky
but we can't quite make out what they're
looking at after a few moments
we see a giant shadow in the shape of a
dragon fly right over top of them
they look happy for its arrival the
flashback goes to the next
scene now we see arya stark in the woods
surrounded by wolves
this was when she reunited with nymeria
and all we get is a glimpse of this
then it flashes to the next scene brian
stark is inside the old throne room of
the red key
we're not able to hear anything at first
but we can see he's having a
conversation with a large man dressed in
house stark's brown leathers
with a horrific looking scar on his face
as soon as brain signals for the man to
step in closer
we're suddenly able to hear what he says
next in a low voice
bran says when you return i will make
you the master of whisperers
then we go to another flashback scene
now we're back inside the three-eyed
raven's cave
we are looking through the eyes of a
raven we don't see anyone inside
other than some dead bodies and the
bones on the ground
it looks like the inside of the cave was
on fire most of the roots of the
werewold are now blackened with ash
the raven takes flight and we begin
going deeper into the cave
where no living man has gone before some
of you might not know this but the
three-eyed raven's cave is actually
massive
it's not only one level like we saw in
game of thrones
it goes down deep into the earth the
raven is now flying through complete
darkness
after what feels like several minutes
the raven finally lands inside a chamber
we've never seen before
there are lots of candles burning along
the wall
the floor is covered in what looks like
hundreds of years worth of melted wax
in the back of the chamber there are
roots of the werewood shaped into three
weirwood thrones
the raven flaps across the room and he
begins walking up and down the roots of
the weirwood
when the bird looks down we can see
there are three very old members of the
children of the forest
they have long white hair with very long
white beards
at first they look like they're dead but
right before the flashback scene ends
one of them opens his eyes scaring the
raven away
now these next few scenes happen really
fast now we're in winterfell's godswood
we hear bran say to jaime how do you
know there is an afterwards
what about afterwards how do you know
there is an afterwards
then we see jon stab daenerys in front
of the iron throne
then we see brain and king's landing we
hear him say
why do you think i came all this way
will you lead the seven kingdoms to the
best of your abilities
from this day until your last day
[Music]
why do you think i came all this way
we see ned stark behead the night's
watch deserter
we see the iron throne before it was
melted
then we hear bran say to john you are
exactly where you were supposed to be
i'm sorry i wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
now some of these scenes indicate bran
stark knew what would happen in the end
now we're back inside the three odd
ravens cave we hear
leif explain why they created the night
king
we were at war we're being slaughtered
our sacred trees cut down we needed to
defend ourselves
from whom from you
in this final flashback scene we see the
night king when he laid his finger on
the face
of one of craster's sons we're about to
finally see what happens after this
when the baby's eyes became blue the
night king gets back on his horse while
holding the baby
we see him as well as all the other
white walkers ride back to their castle
in the lands of always winter we follow
them as they walk inside the castle
then down a flight of stairs they enter
what looks like a crypt
similar to winterfell's the only
difference is everything in this castle
was either made out of ice or carved
into it
the night king bends down to set the
baby on a large block of ice
right as the night king stands back up
we get a better view of just how big
this crypt actually is
what it really looks like is an
underground mine shaft that stretches
out like very long fingers
into many different directions it makes
one wonder where they all lead
because you can only see so far into the
dark but this isn't the most shocking
reveal
right over the night king's shoulder we
can see there are dozens of babies
laying on blocks of ice
the blocks are in single file lines
stretching down each one of the shafts
until they disappear into the darkness
the flashbacks end when we cut to bran
stark sitting in the chair
his eyes are still rolled back in his
head but there's something different
about them
they're not as white as they used to be
they have somewhat of a blue haze to
them
after a few moments they flip back to
normal then we immediately cut to the
opening theme
like i said before all of these
flashback scenes will happen in the very
first episode before the opening credits
all of them foreshadow some of the major
events that will happen in this season
now i know it took me several minutes to
explain what happened in all of the
scenes but you have to imagine how fast
all of this would happen if you saw it
on the screen yourself
each of the scenes would fly by really
fast because you would be able to see
and hear everything without me having to
describe it all
hopefully you will remember all of this
moving forward
now let's begin so after we see brain's
flashbacks
and then the opening credits the first
official scene will begin
out beyond the wall the sun is just now
beginning to set
as we see jon and ghost still traveling
with the small group of wildlings
john and tormund are up front leading
all of them through the dense forest
you should start back tormund giantsbane
said as the woods began to grow dark
around them
the white walkers are dead the wall is
still broken at east's watch
there is no need for a night's watch
anymore there are no longer any threats
living out beyond the wall
john said i don't intend on staying at
castle black ever again
besides i had to swear i would never
ride south
they can have the seven kingdoms i'm
done fighting
with a slight grin on his face tormund
says
i knew you had the north in you boy the
real north
if you're staying with us we should stop
soon i will make you a fire
i know how you southerners get cold in
the night i can make my own fires john
said half smiling himself then he says
we will set up camp soon
we're almost there in the following
scene we're back in winterfell where
sanja stark is now queen of the north
the scene begins as we see her and the
maester walking around the grounds of
the castle
winterfell is still in shambles there
are dozens or even hundreds of men and
women running around
and working in several different areas
we can see there are men working on the
exterior walls of the castle
there are women butchering meat there
are men and women carrying in
large stone blocks it will be years
before the castle looks like it once did
we follow sansa stark as she walks out
to the godswood alone
she sits down under the werewood where
we have seen her and so many other
starks sit before
sansa sits there in silence as she looks
around at all the red fallen leaves on
the ground
soaking up the white snow underneath it
looks as if she is in deep thought
as she most likely thinks about
everything that has happened to her
and her family after a few more moments
of silence
she looks back at the face that's on the
werewood we can hear her take a deeper
breath when she looks at it
the face now looks slightly different
than it did before it still
sort of looks like bran but somewhat
darker
there's something about it that makes
sansa feel very uncomfortable
because she immediately looks away from
it then abruptly stands up to leave the
godswood
as she begins walking forward she steps
on something
making her look down to see what's under
her foot she bends down to brush away
some of the snow
whatever it is she sees is stuck because
she has to yank at it to rip it free
from the frozen ground
she stands back up while holding the
object in her hands
sanza isn't sure what she's looking at
but she can feel it's made out of some
sort of metal
suddenly she drops it back in the snow
then she begins rubbing her hands
together
hoping to warm them back up whatever
sansa was holding was so cold
she could even feel it through her thick
gloves sansa doesn't realize it
but she had found the symbol the night
king wore on his armor
it must have broken off when arya
stabbed him we now see the maester
walking to the godswood
when sansa sees him approaching she says
what is it
the maester says your grace there is
something you should see
as sansa walks away the scene ends as it
focuses on the metallic symbol laying in
the snow
in the following scene we go down to
king's landing where sam
gilly and little sam are finally getting
settled into their new living quarters
inside the red key
we see sam as he sets down a large stack
of books on the table
we can see some of the books are about
different subjects like language
history medicine and even magic gilly
asks what are all those for
they just arrived from the citadel says
sam bran has made arrangements for me to
continue my studies while we stay here
with a big grin on his face he says they
will send me new books whenever i need
them
i may have been chosen as the new
maester but i still have so much to
learn
speaking of books i should send them
back the ones i stole
sam walks across the room and grabs
another stack of books
he opens one of them up and we can see
it shows arya's dagger inside
this is one of the books sam stole the
same one he was looking through when he
discovered the dragonglass in season 7.
he looks at the dagger for a few moments
then says i guess we really didn't need
all these books in the end
the dragonglass helped but it was
valerian steel that killed the night
king
he slams the book shut then grabs
another one this one says
legends of the long night we saw this
book in season seven as well
when gilly was reading it sam focuses on
the front of the book
which looks like it has a skeleton on
the front this skeletal looking creature
is standing on the moon
while the sun is hiding behind him but
that's not what sam is focusing on
he looks at its hands in one hand it has
what looks like one of the white walkers
ice swords but in the other hand
it's holding what looks like a dagger
sam looks very confused
right before this scene ends we see him
suddenly grab the other book
he opens it back up then finds the image
of the dagger again
he looks at ghillie then says i will
need to write a letter
in the next scene we're on the beach
just below the red key
we can see braun davis and tyrion
walking along the shore
we also get a great view of king's
landing from here we get a good look at
just how much was destroyed by daenerys
and drogon
we begin following them as they are
walking on the beach
why are we here there are some young
ladies waiting for me in the city
you can have them afterwards when i'm
done with them braun said to tyrion
with a sly look on his face you can have
your fun later says tyrion
we still have work to do this entire
city needs rebuilt from the ground
up now he looks at davos and says you
and i both know this city has its
weaknesses
even without dragons cities have rose
and fell for thousands of years
it nearly fell the night you and stannis
came across the black water
westeros is on its knees right now
recovering from years of bloodshed
with a large enough force this city
could be easily overran again
overran by who says braun the only
reason this city needs rebuilt is
because of your lovely dragon lady
she's dead we have no enemies right now
the unsolid
and dothraki are gone you saw them set
sail the same as i did
the seven kingdoms are actually working
together are they not
it's not the seven kingdoms i worry
about says tyrion
have you spent much time across the
narrow sea he says to bronn
only a little the wine is good but i
prefer our brothels said brawn
daenerys had her foes everywhere she
went but there are those across the
narrow sea who still love her
i have seen it with my own eyes says
tyrion the seven kingdoms are wide open
right now
the unsullied and dothraki aren't the
only armies who have been decimated
look around here do you see armies in
the thousands guarding this city
no says braun who now looks annoyed we
see tyrion look out across the water
i'm afraid of what might be coming i
don't think i need to remind either of
you
drogon is still out there somewhere he
now looks at davos again
and says one day we might look out
across this water
and see a new army on the horizon who's
on its way to take this city
i just hope we're ready when that
happens in the next scene
we go across the narrow sea to essos in
the city of atlantis
this scene opens up as we see a large
banner flapping in the wind
on this banner is a burning heart the
symbol of relore
it sits atop one of the largest
buildings we have ever seen we are now
at the red temple of the lord of light
it is sitting high up on the hill
the temple is a hundred different hues
of red yellow
gold and orange it looks as if the stone
was made out of fire itself
at its base just outside of its walls is
an army of what looks like a thousand
men
this is the fiery hand an army of slave
soldiers who guard this sacred structure
they're all holding back a crowd of
thousands of followers over lore
at the very top of the steps there are
several high-ranking members of relore
each of them are dressed in red silk
robes with hoods covering their faces
each of their red silk robes are covered
in the same symbols we have seen on
melisandre's necklace
one of the men even has the symbol
branded on the center of his forehead
they're all standing in front of the
entrance which has very large doors that
have the burning heart engraved into
them
in front of them is the largest and
deepest brazier we've ever seen
with a fire burning inside that reaches
100 feet into the sky
these high ranking members are standing
in a circle around the fire
chanting something in high valyria as
the chants get louder and louder
men and women in the crowd below begin
weeping
the fire starts reaching higher and
higher into the sky
it begins burning so bright everyone in
the crowd has to shield their eyes
swirling around inside this massive fire
is what looks like the head of a dragon
the chanting in high valyria continues
to get louder and louder
as the fire keeps reaching higher and
higher into the sky
the fire is beginning to burn so hot the
army of slave soldiers has to take a
step forward to move away from its heat
one of the men in the red robes feints
falling to the ground
as soon as his body hits the ground his
hood falls back
revealing his face we can see his eyes
are rolled back in his head
with blackened blood running out of his
nose suddenly
all of the high ranking members of
relore fall silent
right as everyone in the crowd begins
looking at each other wondering what
just happened
they hear a sound unlike anything they
have ever heard before
it is the sound of a dragon its screech
is so loud everyone gathered outside now
has to shield their ears
those who were once frightened now have
a look of happiness
as a shadow of very large wings flies
over their face
the dragon slams down right on top of
the red temple of her lore
as it lets out another thunderous scream
the dragon flaps its wings again then
lifts off the top of the building now
landing below
in front of the main entrance where the
members in the red robes are gathered in
a circle by the large fire
we see it as drogon who gently lays
dany's body down on the ground
someone in a red robe begins walking
forward over to her body
when they're standing over danny's
lifeless body they remove their hood
revealing who they are the scene ends as
we see a smiling kinvara
look down at daenerys in the following
scene we are back in winterfell
only now we're down below in its crips
we can see there are men and women
working down here as well
they are doing everything they can to
restore it to what it once was
we can also see several men wheeling
down a new statue of ned stark
as you all know most of the statues were
shattered on the main level during the
battle in winterfell
not all of them were broke due to the
dead breaking out of them however
some of them were simply knocked over
and smashed from everyone running around
down here
trying to flee from the attack it does
look like most of the crypt has been
fixed
now we begin to follow sansa stark and
their maester as they walk further into
the crypt
sansa says it feels strange being down
here again
i usually don't go any further than my
father and aunt statues
it has been many years since i have went
this far my sister
and all my brothers loved hiding down
here when they were little
i hated whenever they would ask me to
join them in a game of monsters and
maidens or coming to my castle
i was always so afraid of wandering
around these lower levels
don't you worry your grace there are
guards all over this castle ready
and willing to die for you we're almost
there now
it's just up ahead says the maester it's
beginning to get colder and colder
as they walk further and further into
the crypt there aren't as many candles
down here either
on the main level there are several
candles at each statue
but down here there is maybe one for
every other statue
the faces on the statues are also
beginning to look more and more stern
as they go deeper into the cavernous
vault finally sansa is able to see a few
of their men
standing just up ahead when she reaches
them she says
what's wrong why did you have me come
all the way down here
we are sorry your grace but we needed to
ask you a question
when does it end said one of the men
when does what end
ask sansa the crypt your grace we have
been down here working for nearly a
fortnight
we wasn't sure how far we should go
because it doesn't seem to end
well the statues end but the crypt does
not do you know how far it goes or where
it leads
said one of the men my father always
said there are many many levels down
here but i've only been on a few when i
was younger he would never allow any of
us to go to its deepest level
as soon as you reach that you won't be
able to go any further anyway
because he always said the ceiling was
collapsed down there
we found the collapsed ceiling six days
ago your grace we had several men remove
some of the large stones
then we dug out the rest that is where
the statues end
the last few days we have sent men
further than that they say the entire
ground is frozen
once you go deeper into the darkness it
doesn't seem to end your grace
sansa says i don't know no one has ever
gone that far before
not even my father the maester says i
will look at all the records
maybe there is some mention of it there
is one other thing your grace said one
of the stark men
there are drawings down here on the wall
they look old
mayhaps thousands of years old drawings
of what
says sansa this scene ends as the man
says
it would be best if you had a look for
yourself your grace
in the next scene we are back out beyond
the wall we're not exactly sure where
this is
because everything out beyond the wall
almost looks the same
the one thing we will recognize is the
werewood it might even be the same
location where bran hodor mira and jojen
stopped once before
we spend a few moments as we watch some
of the wildlings set up their camp for
the night
some of the wildlings are also skinning
animals for later
jon snow makes a large fire for everyone
to gather around
then he takes his seat right in front of
the weirwood leaning his head back
against it
everyone looks like they're in good
spirits the children fall asleep almost
immediately
while the adults break out the good ale
for a night cap
john says you know this might be the
first time i will be able to sleep
out beyond the wall without having to
worry about being killed in my sleep
tormund giant's bane laughs then says if
you don't hand over that drink
you won't have to worry about anything
ever again now they're both laughing
you know i'm glad you're here with us
snow but we have some long days ahead of
us
we should all get some rest while we
still can everyone begins muttering as
they walk away from the fire
john says you're right as soon as i
finish this drink
john takes another big gulp of his ale
then leans his head back against the
weirwood
as he closes his eyes we see everyone
else getting under their furs around the
fire
we see ghost snuggled up right next to
jon's feet
the reflection of the fire is glowing
inside his red eyes
now we see john again who looks like
he's already fallen asleep
as we look around the fire everything
slowly fades to black
but only for a few moments we suddenly
hear the sound of a soft
old voice that says look for me as we
see an image of the massive weirwood
above the three-eyed raven's cave
look for me
only it's not his voice it's the voice
of someone else
now we see the night king on his horse
holding the baby
while they're heading to the ice castle
in the lands of always winter
we see john reuniting with brian stark
we hear john say look at you you're a
man
then we hear brain say almost
look at you you're a man
almost
we see john again but now he's bending
his knee in front of bran
he says i'm sorry i wasn't there when
you needed me
brain says you are exactly where you
were supposed to be
i'm sorry i wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
we see the massive werewolf above the
cave again we see the night king's
creation
we see arya stab the night king with her
dagger
we see bran in the old throne room of
the red key
speaking to a man we have never seen
before the man has a hideous looking
scar
on his face now we see daenerys burning
everything in king's landing
then the scene fades to black again the
very last thing we see is a massive fire
burning with smoke all around it
after only a few seconds the fire goes
out we see a silhouette standing within
the smoke
as the silhouette steps out from the
smoke we can see they're nude
with a large stab wound in their chest
when they lift up their head
we can see it's dany stepping out from
the smoke
johnsono's eyes fly back open as he
begins gasping for breath
everyone who was sleeping around their
campfire is now awake
holding a weapon in their hand wondering
what's happening the scene ends as jon
looks over
at tormund horrified okay now before i
go to my final scene in the episode let
me just explain one thing
some of you might be wondering how this
happened to john he was able to see
all of these different things because he
fell asleep while his head was laying
against the werewood
now what i did was very different but
something like this does happen in the
book
jaime lannister has a very strange dream
while he's laying his head on a weirwood
stump
john's was different he's in the north
out beyond the wall
this werewood hasn't been cut down like
the one jaime fell asleep on
not only that but jon also has the blood
of the first men
as well as a direct connection to bran
stark who is one with the werewolf net
now i don't want to explain any more
than that otherwise i might reveal
too much information right now just make
sure you remember
all the things he saw from my final
scene in the episode
we are out at sea on one of the stark
ships
we can see men working around the ship
grabbing ropes
moving the sails carrying things and
much more
we will see arya stark emerge from below
the ship
with a man who looks like he might be
the captain we hear them discussing the
route she wants to take as they move
west
the man says it has been days since we
left sunspear my lady
we will have nothing but the summer sea
ahead of us before we see the arbor
good says arya i can't wait to leave
westeros behind me
the man tips his hat then walks away we
follow arya back below the deck
as she heads for the main cabin as soon
as she enters
she shuts the door behind her at first
she doesn't notice there is a man
standing behind her door
in the shadow we're not able to see his
face but we see the light glimmer off
his small
dagger when the door shuts he slides the
bolt over
locking them inside the room arya hears
the bolt locked shut
as soon as she spins around to see what
it was she sees the man is already
lunging at her
they both fall down to the floor as they
struggle for control of the man's dagger
arya finally gets a glimpse of the man's
face but it doesn't look like she
recognizes who it is
it's obvious this isn't the man's first
fight arya isn't able to gain control of
the situation
as fast as she'd like what she does
notice is he has a nasty looking scar
that stretches across both sides of his
face
after rolling around on the ground for a
while arya finally subdues the man's arm
that's holding the dagger
while she uses her other hand to free
her own dagger from its sheath
arya now has the man in full mount
holding his arms down under her knees
she brings her own dagger up to the
man's throat demanding to know who he is
the man doesn't answer arya shoves her
dagger into his neck
just far enough to get him bleeding arya
then says i will let you live
if you tell me who sent you the man
still doesn't answer
she shoves her dagger into his neck a
little further while also using her
other hand to apply pressure to his
throat
who sent you the man is now gurgling
there is some blood coming out of his
mouth
who sent you she says again while
struggling to breathe
the man says it was the king
arya is stunned she lets go of the man's
throat
he immediately grabs at it while gasping
for air
arya can't believe what she just heard
it feels like her head
is spinning why would my brother want me
dead arya says
she looks down at the man shocked almost
as if she forgot what just happened
he says let me up you said you would let
me live
arya slowly gets up feeling somewhat
dizzy
she says it again why would my brother
want me dead
i don't understand the man stands back
up
then heads for the door before he can
grab the handle
arya spins him back around then slashes
his throat
arya just stands there for a few moments
still stunned by what the man said
she drops her blood soaked dagger to the
floor the episode ends
as it focuses on the valyrian steel
dagger
[Music]
so
you